this story um is one i didn't pay much
attention to at the beginning because as
i heard about it i thought this has to
be a joke there's no way
republicans are this stupid but
unfortunately anytime your instinct is
republicans couldn't possibly be this
stupid
take a step back and investigate because
republicans really could be this stupid
republicans are blaming joe biden's
administration
for a shortage of some sauces at the
chicken
chain chick-fil-a often affiliated with
homophobic right wing ideology
i thought it was a joke but it's real
chick-fil-a announced that it was going
to limit how much
sauce it would give customers because of
an industry-wide
supply chain issue so customers will
only get one cup of sauce per item
now i've never been to a chick-fil-a but
a cup of sauce
seems like a lot i've never needed a cup
of mayonnaise
for a meal i've never needed a cup of
ketchup or a cup of mustard for any meal
i've ever had
let's put that aside for a second
radical trumpian congresswoman lauren
bobert tweeted in response to the sauce
shortage quote is there no limit to how
awful biden's america can get
ted cruz tweeted joe biden is destroying
america
about the sauce shortage oklahoma
republican governor
kevin's tit uh his re-election campaign
now claims that quote joe biden's
radical liberal policies
are to blame for the sauce shortage at
chick-fil-a
his campaign published a whole thing
saying chick-fil-a
a gas sauce a chick-fil-a sauce shortage
uh gas shortage you want to know why
because of joe biden's radical liberal
policies now of course gas stations
had the shortage because of what
happened to a pipeline not because of
joe biden
gas prices are up and they have been
during the end of trump's term
because of increased demand as we come
out of the pandemic
and now supposedly chick-fil-a has a
sauce shortage
also because of joe biden and it seems
like a joke
but it is really not now kevin's tit
also said groceries are costing more
that's true
but that started before biden and it
doesn't have anything to do with joe
biden now i tried
in order to do this story justice to
find out exactly
how they believe biden caused a sauce
shortage
i couldn't find it my guess is it's
something about
biden didn't fix something related to
supply chains or biden didn't open fast
enough
something which would have fixed supply
chains i don't know
it doesn't make much sense but my guess
is that it would be something like that
that entire thanks obama thing from the
obama era where people would pretend to
blame obama for the silliest thing
i stubbed my toe my toe i got a paper
cut thanks obama
republicans today are making it a
reality with joe biden and chick-fil-a
now someone please explain to me why do
you need so many sauces at chick-fil-a
is the food not good and you need to
mask it with
endless cups of sauce you just need
massive dumps of multiple sauces
i've never been to a chick-fil-a i don't
understand why the sauce controversy is
such a controversy
but maybe someone can explain it to me
remember that monday memorial day
we're getting very close now my friends
monday memorial day we're doing a
one-day membership special this is such
an outrageous discount off of membership
that i can't even tell you what it is
now but if you want to be notified on
memorial day it's very easy
you go to davidpakman.com you sign up
for my newsletter
and on monday memorial day you will get
a perfect email
telling you exactly how to take
advantage of this great discount
we have a great program for you today
looking forward to hearing from some of
you answering some of your questions and
much more coming up
stay with us find me on twitter at
deepakman
one of our sponsors is four sigmatic the
company best known for their delicious
mushroom coffee four sigmatics mushroom
coffee is
organic fair trade single origin
arabica coffee with both lion's mane and
chaga mushrooms chaga mushrooms have
actually been shown to have potential in
supporting the immune system
in peer-reviewed studies i've been
drinking four
sigmatic coffee a lot lately it actually
doesn't taste anything like mushrooms it
just tastes like
any delicious coffee but it's really
easy on my stomach doesn't give me any
jittery feeling or a midday crash and
they have over
20 000 five-star reviews
and best of all if you don't love it
you'll get 100 percent of your money
back because
they stand behind their product you've
got nothing to lose by giving it a try
four sigmatic is giving my audience up
to forty percent
off and free shipping when you go to
four sigmatic dot com slash pacman
the link is right underneath this video